So let's take a look at this
line with negative slope and
see how we can calculate its value.
First, I'm going to find two points that
the line seems to really go through.
Not here, the line just passes close but
doesn't go through it, same with here.
It goes through this point.
And it looks like that point
has coordinates (-3, 2).
I could also use the point (0,
0) but I don't really want to.
Let's use a different one.
Nope, nope, this one, and
it looks like that has coordinates 3,-2.
Now when I think of how the line
changes between these points.
Well, vertically, when calculating
the rise, it changes by, well, -4.
It goes down four, and the run, well,
it's still going to the right, so
I'm going to call that
a positive number.
And it looks like it's six.
So if I were to calculate the slope,
I would get rise
-4 over run 6 and
that simplifies to -2/3.
Now, time for you to practice.
So can you tell me what's
the slope of this line?
Enter your answer in these boxes,
rise over run.